so you're an executive producer i want
to start with the executive producer
part yeah five more minutes you got uh
the movie that came out now tell us
about how how was that experience for
you it was so cool i mean you write
these songs and they're coming from the
heart but you're really just writing
songs to play the songs and for you and
the fans and all that you never think
anything else outside of that's going to
happen so when we got the call they
wanted to do a movie on this and it was
gonna be hallmark and then the christmas
season and they own the christmas season
it's like oh man that's awesome and they
did such a good job with it and tying in
the songs and
might have shed a little tear or two
while i was watching it oh yeah it got
me it got me are you i'm an emotional
guy or like a like a romantic movie kind
of guy like yeah you know when you're a
married man sometimes you just got to
sit down and watch those movies
uh i mean all those like sparks movies
like walk to remember or uh
what was um
the notebook what what place is your
spot where you write do you have a spot
in the house where every time i go to
the spot i know i'm gonna get something
yeah i convinced her to let me change
one of our guest bedrooms into a studio
so i've got my recording gear there my
piano my guitars and that's kind of
that's i basically made the whole album
in that room at least wrote it basically
in that room what is one message you
want to say to her on new year's eve
during this show new year's eve next
year is going to be our best year yet
baby i'll tell you
you know it's it's every year is i'm i'm
the luckiest dude me and her met when we
were five years old in kindergarten
class and we grew up together our whole
way so um she's soft to the earth
awesome lady so i'm lucky to have her so
what's your goal for 2022 and beyond you
know i just i'm always trying to learn
and just learn more about me as a guy
life in general artist country music um
i want to write more songs in 2022 and
um start to finish and just see what we
come up with you know even though we're
not making a full apple next year just
you know have fun with it so next year
let's just go into it with full heart
love your neighbors love your friends
and let's all
go in it together let's build each other
up and make 2022 the year that it's